Remember, the entropy is the sum over all the class labels
of -P log2 (P).
So what's the entropy of the children once we make this split?
So I have two class labels that are available to me, the slow and the fast.
We'll start with slow, so Pslow is two-thirds.
So that's what I'm going to put in here.
Negative two-thirds, log base two of two-thirds.
And now we do the calculation for the fast component.
So Pfast is one third, so this -1/3 log2 (1/3)
Now you do the calculation and
write the decimal value of this expression into the box there.
Remember if you need to do the log base 2 calculation,
one of the things that I found really helpful is the math module in Python.